c'est une icône du 21e siècle
vous connaissez tous son visage bill
gates fondateur de microsoft
bonjour c'est une occasion unique
aujourd'hui nous avons travaillé dur
pour créer cette nouvelle version de
windows
nous sommes très excités à l'idée de
voir comment les gens vont l'apprécier
roi de l'industrie du logiciel
il y a plus de 30 ans le jeune bill
gates est l'un des premiers à avoir
prophétisé que le micro-ordinateur
allait envahir nos bureaux nos maisons
nos vies
comptait écrire communiqué se divertir
aujourd'hui allumer son ordinateur
c'est à voir bill gates derrière son
écran ces logiciels font tourner près de
neuf ordinateurs sur 10
une révolution qui a fait la fortune de
bill gates et de son empire
microsoft
génie visionnaire pour certains
dangereux businessman pour d'autres bill
gates depuis toujours n'a qu'une seule
obsession sa réussite et m'expliquer sur
un tableau blanc très précisément
comment il allait conquérir le monde aux
états unis
votre réussite se juge à l'argent que
vous gagnez c'est le meilleur moyen
qu'on ait trouvé pour mesurer la
réussite
alors il a tout de suite voulu gagner le
plus d'argent possible
il a toujours corées après le pouvoir il
doit toujours être le numéro 1 qu'il ne
conçoit pas autre chose
l'histoire de cet homme obsédé par sa
propre réussite
comment sur la côte ouest des états unis
à seattle surnommé jet city à cause de
la présence du puissant constructeur
boeing
né en 1955
bill gates grandi dans le quartier
résidentiel le plus huppé de la ville
car c'est leur rejeton d'une famille
fortunée
son père est un avocat réputé sa mère
femme au foyer s'investit dans les
oeuvres caritatives
les parents du petit ben ils vont tout
faire pour lui inculquer dès son plus
jeune âge
l'esprit de compétition leur fils doit
être le meilleur surpasser les autres
il a grandi dans un environnement
familial où l'on organisait tout le
temps des tournois de jeux ça pourrait
être des jeux de cartes et jeux de
société des jeux de stratégie et il
adorait gagner quitte ça explique son
goût pour la compétition depuis le plus
jeune âge
son père est alors son modèle c'est l'un
des plus grands avocats de la ville sa
réussite le fascine dès l'âge de 10 ans
bill n'a qu'un objectif réussir lui
aussi alors contrairement à ses petits
camarades qui jouent au baseball
il préfère passer son temps plongé dans
cette encyclopédie en 22 volume qu'il
apprend page après page
il avait déjà un qi très élevé 180
certains de ses professeurs m'ont dit
qu'il était supérieur à celui d'un génie
il avait une mémoire visuelle incroyable
il était toujours très motivés à se
surpasser
le destin de bill gates va se jouer dès
l'âge de 12 ans dans cette école de
seattle l'ex hight school
car c'est ici en 1967 qui va faire la
découverte de sa vie oui si vous êtes à
lakeside school
c'est dans cet établissement que bill
gates a passé ses années de collège et
de lycée frais d'x-rite l'a bien connu
c'était son prof de maths mais surtout
celui qui lui a fait découvrir un
univers alors inconnu du grand public
l'informatique
l'ex hight school est alors une des
premières écoles du monde équipé d'un
ordinateur
voilà à quoi cela ressemble à l'époque
un ensemble d'énormes machines qui
remplit une pièce entière en cette fin
des années 60
l'ordinateur ne sert encore qu'à
effectuer de savants calculs
statistiques
de l'ordinateur de l'école il ne reste
plus aujourd'hui qu'un vestige ce
clavier il était devant un ordinateur
toutes les après-midi il séchait même
les cours de gym pour s'enfermer dans la
pièce de l'ordinateur
il n'est encore qu'un gamin mais il n'a
déjà qu'une seule idée en tête percer
les mystères de cette machine il va très
vite
étonné son prof de maths on avait beau
lui donner des conseils lui ai proposé
de n'être ça ne servait à rien car ils
maîtrisaient déjà tout il était souvent
très impatient avec les autres élèves
il ne comprenait pas pourquoi il
n'allait pas aussi vite que lui bill
gates n'a que 12 ans mais il est déjà
visionnaire il est convaincu que bientôt
l'ordinateur va bouleverser la vie des
gens mais son intuition c'est que plus
que la machine ce sont les programmes
pour l'utiliser qui vont permettre cette
révolution
en 1968 il rencontre paul allen un élève
qui a deux ans de plus que lui ne se
quitteront plus ensemble ils vont
concevoir leur tout premier programme un
logiciel pour gérer automatiquement les
emplois du temps de toutes les classes
de l'école ils ont passé un temps fou à
travailler sur ce programme de gestion
des emplois du temps de l'école en fin
de compte ils ont réussi à créer un
programme unique un outil beaucoup plus
performant que tout ce qu'on pouvait
imaginer à cette époque
le directeur de l'école les récompenses
à 15 ans bill gates touche son premier
chèque de 500 $ à partir de ce jour là
il a la conviction que fabriquer des
programmes
cela peut devenir un vrai business ces
programmes c'est d'abord il va y va
considérer c'est assez facile de les
écrire parce que lui il est très doux et
ses petits copains aussi il arrive à
cracher des lignes de code comme ça très
très rapidement et très facilement
donc ces programmes on va les écrire ça
va pas nous coûter grand chose à les
écrire
on va les rendre très très cher et on va
se faire un maximum d'argent seulement
voilà en cette fin des années 60
gagner de l'argent en vendant des
programmes c'est la science fiction
car l'informatique est encore très
confidentiel bill gates lui croit à la
fin de ses années lycée alors âgé de 17
ans il n'a plus qu'une ambition monter
sa société de programme mais pas grand
monde ne partage son intuition surtout
pas ses parents pour leur fils est un
extraterrestre ne l'informatique était
quelque chose de totalement nouveau
la plupart des parents n'y connaissais
rien parfois ils ignoraient même
l'existence des ordinateurs pour la
famille qu'est c'était le cas pour eux
leur fils était accro à quelque chose
qui ne comprenaient pas chez les gates
pas question de gâcher ses études avec
ces sottises la réussite sociale passe
forcément par des études de droit pour
faire avocat comme papa après le lycée
bilbon garçon part à l'autre bout du
pays à boston suivre la voie paternelle
vont préparer son droit dans la
prestigieuse université d'harvard
très vite l'étudiant va être rattrapé
par le démon de l'informatique
e
bill gates à 19 ans au cours de droit de
l'université de harvard
ils préfèrent souvent les parties de
poker endiablé mais en 1974
sa vie bascule il vient de découvrir
dans un magazine spécialisé
cette étrange boîte métallique le
premier ordinateur à taille humaine de
l'histoire vient d'être créée une
innovation qui passe inaperçu du grand
public mais pour bill gates
c'est le signe que son ambitieux projet
devient possible
monkey david faisait ses études avec lui
à harvard il se souvient qu'il fallait
alors pas mal d'imagination pour se
rendre compte que cette machine était
l'ancêtre de votre micro ordinateurs
achetés cet ordinateur à l'époque
c'était comme acheter un ordinateur sans
rien dedans aucune mémoire aucun outil
tout ce que vous aviez cd comme une
carcasse de métal
aucun des grands programmes qu'on
connaît aujourd'hui n'existait pas de
windows
pas de mac os ni de world ni l'excellent
absolument rien pour bill gates
c'est une occasion à ne pas rater
billy paul avait en tête de créer un
programme pour que cet ordinateur soit
utilisable par tout le monde avec son
ancien copain de lycée paul allen depuis
devenu barbu il décide de fabriquer un
programme pour cet ordinateur pendant un
mois
le duo travaille comme des forcenés
monty davidoff leur file un coup de main
we worked as mais ont travaillé la
plupart du temps tard le soir parce que
paul avait un boulot à plein temps la
journée que bill et moi on avait nos
cours à l'université
oui on ne l'a pas alors on travaillait
très tard le soir et on faisait la
grasse matinée et ont retourné en classe
l'après-midi pour créer leur programme
be l'épaule n'hésite pas à utiliser en
catimini les ordinateurs de l'université
ce qui est interdit par le règlement
mais nous n'avions pas le droit
d'utiliser les ordinateurs de
l'université pour un projet personnel en
sort en plus paul allen allez dans la
salle des ordinateurs alors qu'il
n'était même pas inscrit harvard des
universités sont est aperçu la mener son
enquête pour savoir ce que nous faisions
comme souvenir qu'ils ont réprimandé
bill gates en lui donnant un
avertissement ce que tu as fait mal ne
tarissent pas de recommencer
bill gates se soucie peu des réprimandes
de l'administration d'harvard
car lui et paul allen ont réussi leur
pari voilà le résultat
sur cette bande qui est l'ancêtre de la
disquette le programme qu'ils ont
inventé bill gates le van 3000 dollars
au fabricant du premier micro-ordinateur
avait en tête l'idée de monter son
entreprise de programme persuadé de
réussir dans ce domaine là pour lui le
meilleur moyen d'y parvenir
c'était de mettre le pied dans la porte
avec ce programme il voulait être le
premier à vendre des programmes de ce
type
nous sommes alors en 1975
bill gates n'a pas encore 20 ans mais
avec l'argent de son premier contrat il
décide de monter son entreprise avec
paul allen il la baptise microsoft
un nom qui annonce la couleur micro pour
petit ordinateur sauf pour programme
mais à l'époque se lancer sur ce créneau
c'est encore un sacré pari les clients
ne court pas encore les rues en 1975
dans le monde y avait environ 2000
micro-ordinateurs ça ça devait s'appeler
veut peut-être pas encore comme ça qui
était le marché que visez les fondateurs
de microsoft donc vous imaginez il
fallait calme vraiment croire au
développement de ce marché pour penser
qu'on pouvait créer une entreprise
commerciale devant des programmes et
vivre de ceux de ce marché là microsoft
une aventure incertaine mais qu'importe
bill gates plaque harvard au grand dam
de sa famille immédiate chauffeur
il a fait le choix de diriger microsoft
au lieu de retourner à l'université me
disais qu'il avait beaucoup de pression
de sa famille surtout de son père pour
qu'il finit ses études et qui descend
diplôme comme ça ils auraient quelque
chose pour se retourner en cas d'échec
je pense qu'il voulait toujours qu'il
étudie le droit mais lui il n'a jamais
été au bout de retour sur la côte ouest
le duo microsoft s'installe dans un
petit bureau d'une centaine de mètres
carrés dans la banlieue de seattle
dans ce building au 8e étage en 1978
microsoft n'est qu'une petite pme de 11
salariés
voilà l'équipe des débuts ils
ressemblent plus à des hippies qu'aux
cadres d'une entreprise en bas à gauche
ce visage de gamins c'est celui du boss
bill gates et c'est lui qui va chercher
les clients
à droite le barbu c'est son associé paul
allen cette mamie de 69 ans a vécu de
l'intérieur les débuts de l'aventuré
myriam l'ubo était la secrétaire de bill
gates
nostalgique elle a gardé dans son album
photos des souvenirs de cette époque
c'est l'une des choses les plus
précieuses que je possède hockey étaient
seize ça voilà la photo de ce que
j'appelle le gant microsoft hmong sont
meilleurs end aujourd'hui elle en parle
avec beaucoup de tendresse mais pourtant
au départ c'était plutôt mal parti
myriam se souvient encore de sa stupeur
le jour de son entretien d'embauché
lorsqu'elle a vu pour la première fois
bill gates son futur patron
one day ce jour-là un gamin est entré il
avait des lots cheveux pas coiffés en
jean et en baskets
il a passé la porte en disant salut
s'est dirigé tout droit vers le bureau
du boss
et puis il est entré dans la pièce des
ordinateurs je me suis précipité vers
les autres employés en disant qu'il y
ait un gamin qui est entrée dans la
pièce et diouf qu'est ce qu'il faut
faire il sait ça ils ont répondu ce
n'est pas un gamin c'est le président
s'est on bosse j'ai répondu ce gamin est
mon boss araud mais quel âge at il
il a la vingtaine je me suis dit oh mon
dieu il aura bientôt 21 ans ne
t'inquiète pas mon t-il dit alors je
suis rentré à la maison et j'ai raconté
ça mon mari qui m'a dit demain on
regarde le livre des contes et vérifiez
bien s'il a de l'argent
gare à seulement 20 ans il ne va jamais
de payer elle va pourtant découvrir très
vite que le jeune patron de microsoft
est un travailleur acharné
doté d'une ambition sans limites et
ouais ça bien été accro travail ils
avaient une mission tes gars tu es
salaam échelle il faisait tout pour
remplir cette mission à quai mais je
suis rentré au bureau un jour et il
était étendu sur le sol steve hodgson
il s'est évanoui saout celle accordée
qu'est-ce que je dois appeler un médecin
hans this estime m'a dit non il s'est
juste endormi scène while et j'ai dit
mais pourquoi par terre c'est sa voix il
m'a dit c'est passé tout le week end là
pour finir un truc
ne t'inquiète pas il va se réveiller à
les premiers doutes chez lui et puis ils
reviendront est encore en quête chaque
mac et non et je me suis dit ce garçon
est complètement dingue d'animaux qu'il
était tellement fatigués qu'ils
n'avaient même pas pu rentrer chez lui
mais je les connais personne d'autre qui
puisse faire ça nasdaq
obsédé par la réussite de microsof le
jeune bill gates a peu de loisirs
si ce n'est une passion dangereuse pour
la vitesse à l'époque il s'est offert
une porsche 930
pour se détendre ils adorent et conduire
vite direct
ils adorent et rouler le plus vite
possible sur les routes sinueuses de
montagne lui tout c'est un défi il veut
toujours tester des choses aller jusqu'à
limites ou à la quoi que ce soit quand
il conduisait il avait ce qu'on appelle
ici un fausse buster c'est un détecteur
de radars que vous mettez dans la
voiture et qui prévient quand il ya des
policiers sur la route
c'était pour lui un moyen de
décompresser un moyen pour lui en se
concentrant à 100% sur la conduite de
déconnecter totalement mon vieux bill
est ce qu un matin je vais me lever et
entendre dire que le patron de microsoft
est en prison à cause de sa conduite
bill gates se retrouvant en effet
brièvement derrière les barreaux en 1977
mais ce fou du volant va aussi se
révéler un stratège hors pair en matière
de business il va le prouver bientôt en
réalisant la sphère du siècle
à 24 ans seulement bill gates pas
réalisé la sphère du siècle va faire de
lui l'homme le plus puissant de
l'informatique
il s'agit d'un contrat en or avec la
plus grande multinationale américaine
ibm 350 mille salariés à travers le
monde
nous sommes en 1981 ibm domine
l'informatique avec ses gros ordinateurs
encombrant mais la mode change les
petits ordinateurs commencent à faire
leur apparition sur le marché alors ibm
va réagir avec son ordinateur personnel
le voici c'est le pc la carrosserie est
belle mais pour qu'il fonctionne il lui
faut encore un cerveau il lui manque ce
que l'on appelle dans le jargon un
système d'exploitation et ça les
ingénieurs du bm ne savent pas faire
ibm dit bon bah je vais mettre un
système d'exploitation dans mon
ordinateur et se retourne vers ses
équipes est ce que vous avez le système
d'exploitation et l'à une nouvelle fois
les gens me disent nous on n'a jamais
écrit ça parce que nous serons sait
faire les choses pour des gros
ordinateur pour la petite machine que
vous avez peut-être on est incapable de
vous écrire ce que vous me demandez ce
système d'exploitation
demandez le à l'extérieur
les ingénieurs du bm vont croiser le
chemin de notre tout jeune entrepreneur
un peu par hasard c'est la mère de bill
gates qui va faire les présentations
à cette époque marie gates sa mère était
l'une des dirigeantes d'une importante
association caritative c'est là qu'elle
a fait la connaissance d'un trait aux
dirigeants dit bm qui en faisait
également partie elle a incité ce
dirigeant dit bm à prendre contact avec
la société de son fils pour tous deux se
rencontrent et discutent de ce que
microsoft pouvait faire pour eux d'une
certaine manière on peut dire que c'est
la mère de bill qui a permis cette
première rencontre entre ibm et
microsoft le jeune bill gates lors d'un
rendez-vous en floride avec les pontes
du bn au siège de la firme va faire
preuve d'un culot incroyable
d'abord il leur promet l'impossible leur
inventer ce qu'ils recherchent
le système d'exploitation c'est-à-dire
le cerveau de l'ordinateur il s'agit là
d'un programme
autrement plus compliqué que tous ceux
qu'il a développée jusqu'à présent
et bien dit à bill gates est ce que vous
voulez bien faire un système
d'exploitation est ce que vous savez
faire un système d'exploitation et la
scea des premiers grand bluff de
l'histoire de l'informatique bill gates
répond oui alors qu'il n'avait jamais de
sa vie programmé une seule ligne d'un
système d'exploitation me répond il
s'agit d'un mensonge les avis des
dirigeants d' ibm
mais bill gates a en fait une idée
derrière la tête
plutôt que de créer un système
d'exploitation qui ré tout simplement
l'acheter car dans la ville il se
souvient avoir rencontré un crack de
l'informatique team paterson qui
bricolent dans son coin de drôle de
programme
il va lui sauver la mise nous avons
retrouvé ce pionnier de l'informatique
c'est aujourd'hui un jeune retraité il
vit toujours à seattle c'est mon premier
ordinateur que j'ai eues en 1976 qui
volent sur les claviers sont faits
maison
celui ci je les fabrique est entièrement
moi même mais bien sûr ce ne sont pas
ces ordinateurs bricoler qui intéresse
alors le dur de microsoft mais plutôt
une grosse disque est noir
elle contient ce qu'ils recherchent
désespérément un système d'exploitation
fait maison lui aussi son inventeur lui
a donné un drôle de nom cudos c'est une
abréviation peu flatteuses sur asos que
dose ça veut dire vite fait mal fait et
que lorsque je n'ai pas pris le temps de
me fabriquer soigneusement avec mon but
c'était juste le fabriquer un programme
qui fonctionne sur un ordinateur sans
trop perdre de temps c'est pour ça que
je l'appelais vite fait mal fait
tim paterson va céder son invention deux
hommes de microsoft pour 50000 dollars
mais il est loin à l'époque d'imaginer
ce que ces deux acheteurs vont en faire
oui quand ils sont venus me voir ils
m'ont dit nous avons un client qui est
intéressé par ton système d'exploitation
libre au total a dit yu hwan a tout de
suite fait un marché dans lequel il
aboie devant des ce programme à
microsoft qui lui le proposez à un
client alors inconnu et par la suite je
me suis aperçu qu'il s'agissait en fait
dit derrien vous avez été surpris j'ai
pas pu être surpris car je me suis pas
rendu compte de ce que ça représente et
ça aurait pu être n'importe quel client
j'aurais dit ok c'est que je n'imaginais
pas du tout la peine que mon programme
aller à voir avec la force commerciale
du les hommes
à l'époque ça m'a dépassé bill gates
rebaptise le programme qu'il vient
d'acheter ms dos
ms pour microsoft dos pour systèmes
d'exploitation un investissement de 50
mille dollars ça peut paraître énorme
mais en fait bill gates a un plan pour
faire la sphère du siècle car il a une
idée géniale
pas question de vendre son programme à
ibm mais plutôt toucher un pourcentage
sur les ventes des pc
la compagnie devra pour chaque
ordinateur lui verser environ 3 dollars
il vient tout simplement de signer le
contrat de sa vie
c'était un excellent choix stratégique
de bill gates ne pas vendre son système
d'exploitation ibm mais plutôt leur
demander de payer des royalties sur
chaque ordinateur équipé avec ce
programme
ms dos ce qui veut dire qu'à chaque fois
qu'un pc se vend avec le système
d'exploitation de microsoft microsoft
gagne de l'argent
c'est une excellente affaire car le pc
connaît un incroyable succès dès sa
sortie ils étaient 80 il s'en vend 50
mille exemplaires en trois mois
l'amérique découvre alors l'informatique
le pc envahi les écoles les maisons et
surtout les bureaux comme bill gates
avait prédit l'ordinateur devient un
produit de consommation les ventes du pc
dits bm se sont tout de suite en volley
et cela fait de bill gates un homme très
très riche
cela est non microsoft sur le devant de
la scène finit l'ambiance hippies des
débuts la petite pme change aussitôt de
dimension en 1983 microsoft est une
entreprise dont le chiffre d'affaires
atteint les 100 millions de dollars et
occupe maintenant un building entier
dorénavant les cadres dirigeants du
groupe post en costume cravate pour la
photo officielle
bill gates à 27 ans il est ici à droite
richissime sa fortune personnelle
dépasse les 70 millions de dollars grâce
à ces programmes
il contrôle déjà un ordinateur sur deux
en 1984 le magazine time le consacre
alors comme le magicien à l'intérieur de
la machine
il a définitivement volé la vedette à
ibm
mais à l'époque pour lui ce n'est pas
suffisant roland darnton on garde un
souvenir très précis
cet ancien directeur de microsoft a
rencontré le jeune patron ambitieux à
cette même époque
il a tout de suite été impressionné par
son incroyable assurance pendant quatre
ou cinq heures il a fait les cent pas
devant moi il m'expliquer sur des
tableaux blancs très précisément comment
il allait devenir le maître du monde
grâce à ses programmes et pourquoi
microsoft aussi allait devenir la plus
grande compagnie qu'on ait jamais vue
aux états unis cela a duré des heures et
des heures
et finalement il m'a demandé qu'est ce
que tu en penses
alors je lui ai dit bill j'en suis
convaincu tu vas à conquérir le monde
bill gates maîtres du monde
mais avant d'y parvenir il doit régler
un problème de taille qui se trouve sur
sa route
celui qui pourrait être un obstacle aux
ambitions du patron de microsoft
s'appelle steve jobs ce il a le même âge
que bill gates 27 ans lui aussi a créé
son entreprise informatique apple la
marque à la pomme mais lui contrairement
à gates fabrique des ordinateurs
steve jobs se menacent le business de
bill gates avec une machine
particulièrement avant gardiste
le macintosh
c'est alors le premier ordinateur à être
équipé de cet appendice la souris
sur l'écran apparaissent pour la
première fois des icônes et des fenêtres
c'est une véritable révolution
car même un enfant peut maintenant
utiliser un ordinateur
tout cela est possible grâce au cerveau
à l'intérieur de la machine le système
d'exploitation conçu par apple
de l'avis général il a alors dix ans
d'avancé sur celui de libé mpc ce qui va
tout changer c'est le mac avec
l'interface graphique donc à la même
époque on a deux façons d'utiliser
l'ordinateur qui sont complètement
différentes
il y en a il ya une façon il faut
vraiment taper sur un clavier des suites
du sud de caractère qu'il faut apprendre
pour ordonner à l'ordinateur de faire
quelque chose alors que de l'autre côté
on a sur l'écran des petites images de
petites icônes qu'on fait bouger avec la
souris dès sa sortie le macintosh se
vend très bien
il regarde is libé mpc malgré un prix de
vente de 4000 dollars deux fois plus
cher que son puissant concurrent
bill gates est particulièrement inquiet
il doit réagir
si les ventes des pc s'effondre il
risque de tout perdre
nous avons retrouvé à seattle un ancien
ingénieur qui travaillait à l'époque à
microsoft
marlene eller se souvient que son patron
avait du mal à cacher sa jalousie
vis-à-vis de l'ordinateur d'apple bill
était obnubilé par le macintosh
après avoir vu son incroyable graphisme
il disait c'est une invention géniale et
cède et les gens vont adorer ça son
système d'exploitation est bien meilleur
que le nôtre il faut fabriquer le même
mais pour toutes les autres machines aux
machines en somme c'est très simple bill
gates veut percer les secrets du
macintosh
car il veut fabriquer sous sa propre
marque un système aussi évolué avec
l'idée de le vendre aux concurrents
d'apple les pc
mais comment va-t-il s'y prendre depuis
quelque temps bill gates travaille
régulièrement port apple en lui
fournissant des logiciels
à l'époque les ingénieurs d'apple ne se
méfie pas de ce fournisseur
celui ci va en profiter pour se
renseigner discrètement sur les secrets
du macintosh en dit harold était à
l'époque un des responsables du projet
macintosh
je me souviens très bien la première
fois que nous avons montré le macintosh
à bill gates
eh bien c'était comme si nous lui avions
montré son propre avenir tout ce qui
concerne le macintosh intéresse bill
gates il est particulièrement intrigués
par le fonctionnement de la souris il
pose des questions beaucoup de questions
finalement beaucoup trop au goût de
steve jobs
jeter sur le point de lui expliquer
comment marcher la souris si steve a
pressenti ce que je les dires et donc il
a hurlé ferme-la signal très fort
apparemment il n'a pas dû voir que
j'avais compris donc il l'a redit encore
plus fort mais avec des fermes là et
tout le monde la regarde et du genre
message reçu
steve jobs a raison de se méfier mais
c'est déjà trop tard car chez microsoft
une équipe d'ingénieurs travaille
secrètement sur un projet de système
d'exploitation inspiré de celui du
macintosh avec des icônes et des
fenêtres
microsoft s'est toujours défendu d'avoir
copié le macintosh
cet ex ingénieur de microsoft nous donne
un son de cloche légèrement différent
iris est vrai que le jour où le
macintosh est sorti mon boss mon à
donner un exemplaire et la poser sur mon
bureau en me disant on va zy cette bonne
guerre volent tout ce que tu peux dessus
quelques mois plus tard en 1985
bill gates sort un nouveau système
d'exploitation baptisé windows
traduction fenêtre il le propose à tous
les fabricants d'ordinateurs concurrents
d'apple
les wc rattrape une partie de leur
retard technologique et en plus ils sont
vendus deux fois moins cher la marque de
steve jobs ce ne peut lutter
un peu n'avait aucune chance avec leur
propre système ils ont voulu faire la
plus belle jaguar mais ce n'est pas la
voiture que tout le monde peut s'offrir
il voulait la plus belle des machines
c'est ce que jobs ça réussit à faire
mais c'était beaucoup trop cher il a eu
ce qu'il méritait microsoft
on a fait ce qu'on voulait une simple
vol zaien la voiture que tout le monde
peut s'offrir ces dessins windows
dix ans plus tard
95% des ordinateurs de la planète
fonctionne avec le système windows de
bill gates
en 1995 l'homme d'affaires âgé de 40 ans
est à son apogée son entreprise domine
sans partage le monde de l'informatique
depuis lors si at elle n'est plus la
ville de boeing mais celle de microsoft
une multinationale qui emploie alors dix
sept mille salariés
le nouveau siège le campus de redmond
est une véritable ville dans la ville
l'incroyable réussite de bill gates
passe in toute l'amérique
les journaux le présentant maîtres de
l'univers il est même sacré en 95 homme
le plus riche de la planète
sa fortune personnelle frôle alors les
13 milliards de dollars il peut se
permettre de construire la maison de ses
rêves à quelques kilomètres du siège de
microsoft
une bagatelle de 100 millions de dollars
pour une résidence de 5000 m² de surface
plus de 20 chambres 24 salles de bain
cie cuisine plutôt spacieux pour un
couple avec trois enfants
bill gates se promènent pour 30 millions
de dollars le manuscrit original d'un
génie visionnaire de la renaissance
léonard de vinci
l'américain ce jour là ne boude pas son
plaisir
les gens que j'ai toujours admiré le
plus depuis que je suis jeune
ce sont les scientifiques et pour moi il
n'y a pas de plus grands scientifiques
et artistes on avance sur son temps et
comme précurseur que léonard de vinci
ironie de l'histoire c'est à cette
époque que le magicien de l'informatique
va prendre du retard sur son époque et
va passer à côté d'une révolution
technologique majeure
une erreur qui va mettre en péril sa
suprématie
dans le milieu des années 90 une
révolution se prépare
elle va avoir un impact mondial il
s'agit d'internet à l'époque
internet n'est utilisé que par une
poignée d'étudiants et d'universitaires
chez microsoft
certains pressentent qu'internet va
bouleverser notre vie mais bill gates se
montre sceptique tripoli alors oui les
gens chez microsoft hurle on doit se
lancer là dedans il ya plein d'argent à
ce faire diverses ils disaient mais je
ne suis pas sûr de vouloir engager
toutes les forces de travail de la
société dans de cette chose c'est juste
un truc pour les universitaires on verra
attendons de voir si d'autres arrivent à
faire de l'argent avec à san francisco
où une start up californienne a compris
qu'internet va séduire des millions de
gens à travers le monde
son nom netscape la petite entreprise
créée le premier logiciel permettant
grand public de surfer sur internet
on appelle ça un navigateur
à l'époque michael toy faisait partie
des ingénieurs de netsky en 1994 quand
ils commercialisent leur navigateur
le succès est fulgurant on a conçu le
navigateur internet et dès qu'on l'a
lancé des millions de personnes ont
téléchargé
c'est là que tout a commencé gratuit
pour les particuliers
alors si j'étais chez moi que je voulais
un navigateur
il me suffisait de télécharger les
tickets mais l'addition stipulait que si
vous étiez une entreprise il fallait
l'acheter à certaine manière ça nous a
fait une publicité extraordinaire plein
de gens connaissaient ce super truc
appelé les tickets et qu'il pouvait
avoir gratuitement chez eux ils se
rendaient compte à quel point ça
pourrait leur être utile aussi dans leur
travail
trouver des fournisseurs chercher des
références
là il est au service achats de leur
boîte pour dire qu'on venait de skype et
là il devait nous donner de l'argent
pour avoir son navigateur gratuit qui en
fait n'était pas gratuit
le nombre d'accros de la toile explose
netscape se répand sur toute la planète
et devient l'étendard de la révolution
du web
contrairement à ce que croyait bill
gates internet rapporte beaucoup
d'argent
lucette skype été vendus + internet et
des populaires et plus les gens parler
du web
et puis les employés de microsoft disait
oui on doit vraiment son c'est là dedans
c'est l'un des rôles de bill gates
microsoft a toujours été d'être à
l'écouté de ses employés qui livrent
bataille sur le terrain et c'est là
qu'il a dit on va le faire
we're gonna 2 le patron de microsoft
contre attaque et lance son propre
navigateur internet explorer savez
comment on gagne une course de vélo nous
vous ne courrez surtout pas en tête
pendant toute la course
vous restez derrière le leader ou le
laisser mener la course affronter le
vent vous rester dans sa roue
et quand il est rincé vous le dépassez
et vous vous échapper c'était notre
stratégie regarder ce que font les
autres et quand vous voyez là où ils
vont pour faire de l'argent
il est suivi de près voulait doubler
c'est comme ça que ça marche
c'était connu
si vous vous retrouviez dans le
collimateur de microsoft vous étiez
foutu en d'autres termes être foutu ça
signifie être bouffé à balai par
microsoft pour nous c'est devenu
l'obsession
on y pensait constamment votre pour
rattraper son retard
bill gates n'hésite pas à distribuer
internet explorer gratuitement en 1998
c'est la faillite pour netscape mille
gates a remporté la bataille d'internet
mais un nouveau danger se profile car
désormais la justice soupçonne microsoft
d'avoir ont souvent usé de méthodes
illégales pour vaincre netscape
e
le 19 octobre 1998 bill gates se
retrouve devant les tribunaux de son
pays
un process suivie par les médias de
toute la planète
l'affairé sérieuse car c'est le
gouvernement américain qui poursuit la
compagnie de bill gates
ils lui reprochent un des délits les
plus graves aux états unis avoir abusé
de son monopole pour gagner la bataille
d'internet
la sanction peut aller jusqu'au
démantèlement de microsoft bill gates
risque de perdre son empire
christopher friedman faisait partie à
l'époque de l'équipe du ministère de la
justice qui enquêtait sur l'entreprise
de bill gates et ce procès a eu lieu
parce que microsoft avait une manière
très particulière de conduire ses
affaires
leur but n'était pas seulement de gagner
des parts de marché ni d'innover ou même
d'essayer d'être plus compétitif
leur véritable but c'était d'empêcher
toute autre entreprise de programmes de
les concurrencer et de les battre et ça
c'est clairement une violation des lois
à trac de la libre concurrence
quels ont été les méthodes illégales
utilisées par microsoft pour éliminer
netscape
à l'époque la majorité des ordinateurs
vendus dans le monde sont équipés de
l'indispensable système d'exploitation
windows
alors pour forcer les fabricants
d'ordinateurs à ne pas installer le
navigator de netscape
microsoft va utiliser avec succès une
arme redoutable le chantage
il allait voir les grands fabricants
d'ordinateurs comme compaq et d'autre il
leur disait faisons un marché avec six
distribue le navigator de netscape
m'étais uniquement notre navigateur
internet explorer badoit et l'on sera se
montrer reconnaissant si vous refusez
notre marché vous aurez de gros
problèmes
vous n'aurez plus accès à notre système
d'exploitation windows
ce système indispensable pour que vos
ordinateurs restent compétitifs on vous
créera des problèmes si vous ne coopérez
pas et si vous ne bannissez pas
netiquette
le but de cette stratégie c'est
d'empêcher notre équipe d'avoir accès
aux consommateurs
le dossier d'accusation est lourd
preuve à l'appui lankais devra révéler
que ce chantage a été mis en place avec
l'aval de bill gates et de ses
lieutenants
lors du procès microsoft l'amérique
découvre avec stupeur un bill gates
méconnaissable
notamment avec cette vidéo de sa
déposition que nous montre christopher
friedman très mal à l'aise
le roi du logiciel ressemble un
garnement en pris les doigts dans le pot
de confiture
dans cet extrait les magistrats
l'interrogent sur une expression
utilisée par les dirigeants de la
multinationale le djihad microsoft c'est
à dire la guerre sein de microsoft
contre ses concurrents
quand votre bras droit bras chase vous
écris à vous et aux autres dirigeants
nous devons continuer notre djihad
comprenez vous alors qu'il fait
référence à microsoft
quand ils utilisent le mot nous alors
que voulait-il dire en disant nous match
je ne suis pas sûr vous savez ce qu'il
veut signifier par l'expression jihad
jane
aux yeux de la justice américaine mais
aussi pour tous ceux qui le connaissent
le silence de bill gates va avoir un
effet dévastateur
elle est bonne et heureuse toute
personne qui a déjà parlé avec bill
gates c'est qu'il a une mémoire
extraordinaire on peut se rappeler dans
les moindres détails de toutes ces
discussions
même celles vieilles de dix ou quinze
ans concernant microsoft
l'idée même ne se rappelle pas de ceci
ou de cela où qu'ils ne sachent plus la
signification d'un mot mais cela donne
clairement le sentiment qu'ils jouent un
jeu
la conséquence de tout cela c'est que ça
a sérieusement entamé la crédibilité de
bill gates
celui qui était alors encore une icône
un grand héros américain le renversement
d'imagés spectaculaires
caricaturé dans la presse entière en
méchant dictateur bill gates celui qui
quelques années plus tôt était célébrée
comme le magicien de l'informatique
devient l'incarnation du mal absolu
un homme dangereux
tout cela est une bien mauvaise
publicité pour ses affaires pendant le
procès le cours en bourse de microsoft
chute de 30% la fortune de bill gates
mêmes divisées par deux
l'homme d'affaires perd de son assurance
légendaire il va même craqué
c'est clair que tout le procès et toute
la pression qu'il y avait sur microsoft
a pris une tournure très personnel pour
bill gates il ya un conseil
d'administration où il a quasiment fondu
en larmes en racontant qu'il avait des
problèmes de santé qu'il n'arrivait plus
à dormir la nuit
son calvaire va s'éterniser quatre ans
le temps de ce procès fleuve
le juge demande le démantèlement de
microsoft en 2002 microsoft est jugé
coupable
l'entreprise est mise sous surveillance
par le gouvernement avec interdiction de
rééditer de telles méthodes
ce n'est finalement qu'un avertissement
lempire microsoft s'en tire à bon compte
mais bill gates ne supporte pas que son
image était aussi sérieusement noirci un
problème qui lui a vite réparée
e
gare depuis quelques années l'homme le
plus riche de la planète s'est
transformé en bon samaritain accompagné
de sa femme melinda il parcourt
dorénavant les bidonvilles du tiers
monde avec un objectif mettre fin à la
pauvreté la maladie
malaria est une maladie terrible
c'est l'une des maladies pour laquelle
ma fondation investit énormément
c'est très excitant de venir ici au
mozambique rit on voir les résultats des
premiers vaccins réalisé sur 3000
enfants des vaccins qui vont peut-être
réduire les effets de la maladie de
façon très significative vrp
international de l'humanitaire il
participe aux gros concert de charité et
porte la bonne parole aux côtés des
grandes figures de ce monde comme ici
bill clinton tony blair
où le chanteur bono bill gates ne se
contente pas de discours il a créé une
fondation pour lutter contre la misère
ils y consacrent la majeure partie de
son immense fortune
plus de 24 milliards de dollars de
donations ses dépenses dépassent celles
de l'organisation mondiale de la santé
il est devenu le plus grand donateur du
monde
c'est dorénavant à ce titre que la
presse parle de lui time l'a même
consacré homme de l'année 2005
je ne veux pas remettre en cause la
sincérité de son engagement pour la
santé dans le monde mais je pense que
pour une part l'impulsion et le moment
qu'il a choisi de s'investir était
motivée par le désir de redorer son
image
sauver la planète va pourtant devenir un
job à plein temps pour bill gates en
juin 2008 toute la presse en fait sa une
bill gates quitte la tête de microsoft
un départ qu'il célèbre en grande pompe
au siège de l'entreprise
c'est la première fois depuis que j'ai
17 ans que je ne vais plus consacrer
100% de menton à microsoft et la mort je
ne sais pas à quoi va ressembler mon
dernier jour de boulot ça pourrait être
un peu bizarre pour moi alors j'ai
demandé à quelques amies de m'aider à me
préparer pour l'occasion bill gates est
mis en scène dans un clip humoristique
mais qu'est ce n'est pas le riff de
guitare le plus mortel que tu aies
jamais entendu des figurants de marque
se prête au jeu
on en a déjà parlé avant le groupe est
complet désolé ben il n'y a pas de place
pour toi je suis sûr que tu te demandes
qui serait tombée hier qu'au lycée pour
la campagne présidentielle
ah non je n'ai pas encore choisi mon
colistier mais je ne suis pas certaine
que tu sois fait pour la politique
salut c'est bill d'enchaîner shatner de
star trek
non l'autre mobile d'orange clinton
aujourd'hui bill gates sillonne la
planète avec sa femme pour aider les
plus pauvres et les plus défavorisés
avec sa fondation il est aux commandes
de la plus grande organisation
caritative du monde
à 57 ans celui qui rêvait de conquérir
la planète avec ses logiciels s'est
trouvé une nouvelle ambition à sa mesure
être le plus grand bienfaiteur de
l'humanité